hey crazies experience with physics has
taught us that the universe is
inherently local
each point in space can only affect its
immediate surroundings so influence at a
distance must propagate through the
intervening space
and that process is always limited by
the speed of light or is it
quantum entanglement might have
something to say about this
[Music]
before we get into this i should mention
that this video is part of a big collab
for world quantum day but more on that
later
where do i begin
everyone loves a good thought experiment
imagine there's a high energy photon
just minding its own business traveling
along then suddenly an atomic nucleus
jumps out in front of it
the nerve of some nuclei
anyway the interaction transforms the
photon into an electron positron pair
so it collided with the nucleus and
broke apart well
no at least not in the way you're
probably thinking
this isn't like two objects being
smashed together or something particles
never really touch
plus it's it's not like this photon is
made of an electron and a positron
they're not inside there the photon just
ceases to exist and some of its
properties are given to the new
particles
of course energy must be conserved
[Music]
linear and angular momentum are also
conserved and the atomic nucleus helps
with that
yes this particle pair this electron and
positron are anti-particles but they're
so much more than that they're entangled
particles
their properties are linked we know they
must be opposite if the electron is
oriented up the positron must be
oriented down if the electron is
oriented down the positron must be
oriented up
they share a single state it doesn't
make sense to talk about them separately
but this is quantum mechanics so those
two states are not the only ones
available
say we don't know how either of them is
oriented the property is in what we call
a superposition
both particles are showing an essence of
upness and downness at the same time
because you know quantum particles can
do that
they're still entangled though so their
states are still opposite it's just
unclear which of the base states we'll
find when we measure them if you want
more details i have a video on
superposition you can check out later
you know in case you need better
nonsense
available at the science asylum store
but there's really only one more thing
you need to understand right now
superpositions are not measurable
we can only create devices that we
intuitively understand and measured
particles will always be in states that
those devices measure
this random particle's orientation may
be in a superposition but that all
changes when it encounters one of our
devices if the device measures up and
down we'll find that the particle is
either oriented up or down not in a
superposition if the device measures
left and right we'll find the particle
is oriented left or right not in a
superposition
the interaction with the device changes
the particle or at least it changes what
we can know about the particle
and before you ask this has nothing to
do with the person taking the
measurement quantum mechanics is not
magic it's about the information that's
available not the information we have
so now that we have entangled particles
in a superposition let's separate them
and i mean separate them like a lot
we'll put them so far apart that it
would even take light a noticeable
amount of time to travel between them
the earth moon distance ought to do
nicely that's a minimum one-way trip of
1.3 seconds
next we break the universe
i measure the electron here on earth and
find that it's oriented up
in that case i immediately know that the
positron on the moon is oriented down
if astronaut clone measures his positron
it must be oriented down the
superposition has collapsed into this
state
how does that break the universe how did
the positron know to be oriented down
but it was in that state the whole time
wasn't it we just didn't know right well
that's certainly what a whole group of
physicists thought back in the day
to the timeline
quantum mechanics was born in the 1920s
almost a century ago the de bruy wave
hypothesis schrodinger's equation the
heisenberg uncertainty principle all
published in the 1920s and all
suggesting that the universe is
inherently probabilistic it was a
philosophy championed by niels bohr but
then in 1935 albert einstein boris
padalski and nathan rosen published a
joint paper where they outlined a
thought experiment a lot like the one we
just described
this paper was designed to settle a
debate do superpositions physically
exist
can a particle really be in a state that
shows an essence of upness and downness
if that's true then my measured electron
had to communicate with the positron on
the moon instantaneously
just in case astronaut clone decided to
measure his positron at the same time it
didn't have the luxury of waiting the
1.3 seconds it takes light to get there
then again maybe quantum mechanics is
just a statement of our ignorance
maybe there are hidden variables at play
the particles could have definite states
the whole time we just didn't know what
they were
this thought experiment now known as the
epr paradox doesn't truly answer this
question it certainly shows how
counterintuitive superpositions are but
counterintuitive doesn't mean wrong
einstein was involved in the invention
of modern relativity he should have
known better
anyway the debate wouldn't be settled
until 1964 by john stuart bell who
proposed a revised experiment
it turns out that everyone was so
focused on measuring up and down and
left and right that no one thought to
measure along a diagonal
for intelligent beings humans can get
some serious tunnel vision
anyway let's redesign our detectors a
bit
each of the two detectors is capable of
taking a measurement along three
different directions it doesn't matter
which three directions as long as there
are three different directions and the
detectors are designed identically for
simplicity we'll make them all 120
degrees apart
which of the three directions is being
tested will be selected at random for
each particle and the two detectors are
changed independently of each other
next let's label the outward orientation
to be positive for each of the three
directions which makes all the inward
orientations negative by default
then we do this experiment a crap ton of
times
the question is how often do these
particles have opposite signs
if the two detectors happen to be
measuring the same direction we'll get
what we expect two entangled particles
with opposite orientations opposite
signs
but something interesting happens when
the two detectors aren't measuring the
same direction
if they're not then there's no
requirement the signs be opposite they
could be the same
how often we expect those cases to have
opposite signs depends on our philosophy
so this experiment can test if there are
hidden variables
assuming the superposition isn't
physical and the particles had a
definite state the entire time there are
only six possible outcomes so all we
have to do is count if the detectors
measure the same direction the particles
always have opposite orientations as
required by the conservation of angular
momentum if the detectors measure along
different directions the particles only
have opposite signs 1 3 of the time
that's a total probability of 5 9 or
55.6 percent
if quantum mechanics only represents our
ignorance then entangled particles will
have opposite signs in this experiment
55.6 percent of the time but that's not
what we get when we do the experiment
when we go through and do this thousands
of times we get exactly fifty percent
entangled particles have opposite signs
in this experiment exactly fifty percent
of the time
isn't that close enough nope not this
time oh no what does quantum mechanics
predict it predicts exactly fifty
percent
as we saw earlier the quantum
entanglement looks like this we can also
write it like this or better yet like
this since a measures up and down
in quantum mechanics probabilities are
complex squares so the probability of
getting opposite signs when measuring
along different directions would be
written like this
and here's where an author would say
something like the details are an
exercise left for the reader but that's
so not my style
after a ton of work which you can see
right here we get exactly one half or
fifty percent
fifty percent does not equal fifty five
point six percent
quantum mechanics reigns supreme
but but
what does this all mean it means
classical physics is a goner
just put a fork in it
but what this means for quantum
mechanics is a bit more nuanced
locality is the idea that each point in
space can only affect its immediate
surroundings so any distant influence
must travel through the intervening
points in space
does bell's experiment mean that
entangled particles can interact faster
than light yes it does
our classical understanding of locality
is done it can't possibly be true
does that mean superpositions are a real
physical thing
not necessarily it's possible that
entangled particles are just connected
by a wormhole
it's possible that quantum wave
functions don't actually describe the
particles but just describes a new force
some quantum force that affects what the
particles do
it's possible that all outcomes of every
circumstance exist in a quantum
multiverse and we just don't know what
universe we're in until the experiment
is done
what we know for sure is that bell's
experiment shows us that we need to
relax our expectations
thanks for liking and sharing this video
a special thanks goes out to my patreon
patrons and youtube members like fabio
manzini who's been pledging at the
asylum orderly level for over two years
thanks fabio don't forget to subscribe
if you'd like to keep up with us and
until next time remember it's okay to be
a little crazy
so crazy story i was trying to figure
out what my april video was going to be
and then all of a sudden i get this
twitter dm from kyle hill yes that kyle
hill the one running the facility he
tells me that he's been looped into the
white house's participation in world
quantum day yes that white house home of
the us president
as per the website world quantum day is
an international community derivative
event intended to spark interest and
generate enthusiasm for quantum
mechanics
so then kyle says he wants to organize
this big youtube content drop quantum
content or content as we like to call it
of course i say i'm in because i'm just
excited to be invited to a thing but
lots of other creators are dropping
stuff today too check out hashtag world
quantum day on all the platforms to see
more stuff
many of you pointed out that it makes
sense to think of the speed of light as
infinite since light experiences no time
as it moves from one place to another
that's true
while we see light traveling through
space and time the light itself doesn't
experience either one it's almost as if
it teleported anyway thanks for watching